[Musique]
une
j'appelle un petit bac et je suis
restauratrice à cerdon du loiret ce lieu
s'appelle au 2b case parce qu'on est
deux femmes à avoir créé cet endroit il
ya cinq ans moi même et sandrine
martinez moi c'est une pure reconversion
parce que j'étais journaliste et je me
spécialiser recettes vin et oenologie
cuisines et bains la reconversion elle
et elle était assez simple donc on a
trouvé l'endroit ici et on a on a
démarré à cinq ans alors avec sandrine
on va vous réalisez un croustillant de
chair radio et pistaches
pour cette recette il va vous falloir à
sable et un chèvre crottin mariner dans
l'huile et le fenouil des radis des
radis différent d'hier a dit blanc des
radis roses
alors pour la salade ou préfèrent
utiliser des produits par exemple en
hiver de saison le ch ou call qui est
assez peu connu mais qui est assez
sympathique et il va vous falloir une
vinaigrette classique nous on l'a fait à
l'huile de noisette parce que ça va très
bien avec le chef et puis quelques
pistes d'âge pour agrémenter le tout
[Musique]
la ville est net et précis
donc un manteau en emporte pièce
classique
je vais commencer avec sera dit blanc on
va faire un petit des petites
tagliatelles mes petits sablés sont
prêts donc je vais les enfournez dans un
four à 180° pendant une quinzaine de
minutes
ça c'est très joli ces petits radis vert
et en plus chaque radi a un goût
différent
[Musique]
alors regardez là bas voilà ça y est
voilà donc on a ses petits choux call
qui existe en vert et en violet le gros
radis roses les tagliatelles de radis
blanc les tagliatelles dur à divers bien
au chaud
d'un jeu mais les pistaches donc voilà
pour cette recette que tu intitulé
comment alors le croustillant de
chavignol ravier pistache parfait vieux
chien
chacun barque année
[Musique]